oK we've been following the story of
donald trump's supposed medical letter
talking about his absolutely incredible
health where he tested positive for just
everything even though it makes
absolutely no sense to say that he
tested positive and that all the test
results were positive because that means
he actually has a whole bunch of
conditions we now have i don't know if
that that this is a bombshell but it's
certainly incredibly revealing we have
heard now from dr. harold Bornstein who
we weren't even really sure new donald
trump because the letter was so bogus
let's put up the letter just to remind
our audience about all the problems with
this letter of course a typo in that
first sentence to whom my concern
another problem that the letter is
signed by a doctor that is part of the
section of Gastroenterology at Lenox
Hill Hospital there is no such thing it
is the division of Gastroenterology the
entire reference to Trump as the
healthiest individual ever to be elected
to the presidency makes absolutely no
sense dr. Harold Bernstein did not
examine all presidents of the United
States he wouldn't be able to make that
determination
Harold Bernstein's personal gmail
account is on this letter that makes
absolutely no sense well dr. Harold
Bornstein who is pictured here in this
image behind me and and a lot of people
commenting on his physical appearance
although I want to focus today more on
the subject matter of a statement said
in the rush I think some of those words
didn't come out exactly the way that
they were meant explaining that he spent
five minutes on this letter and done
endorsing the health of Donald Trump
also adding that he really made the
letter in a way that was supposed to be
pleasing to the Trump campaign when I
hear that a medical doctor put together
a document in five minutes with the
objective of pleasing the person who
asked for it
I'm not necessarily convinced by what is
the the potentially factual nature of
that letter when I hear a doctor wrote a
document merely to appease the letter
writer
I actually am now emboldened in my call
for Donald
Trump's actual medical records which
we've not seen and it's amazing this
this projection Hillary Clinton is the
bigot is the latest comment from Donald
Trump well actually you're the guy who
has been coalescing of the bigots and
and really catalyzing that area of the
boat Donald Trump saying we need to see
Hillary Clinton's medical records well
it turns out we don't really have your
medical records I want to see Trump's
medical records he would be the oldest
person ever elected president if he were
to be elected in November and to me that
brings up some real questions and we
should have his medical records
particularly after this disturbing
admission from dr. Harold Bornstein this
sounds kind of the thing that you would
see maybe in you know grade school
instead of you know a letter that has
written to our potential president
United States that's all yeah
this reminds me of a letter that you
would fake from your parents to explain
why you were out sick in fourth grade
and maybe because it took five minutes
for dr. Harold Bornstein to write it
that's exactly how it came out I hope
people realize in the midst of the
insane conspiracy theories about oh if
you watch Alex Jones there's a Secret
Service agent who's walking around with
a with an injector to inject Hillary
Clinton with some I don't even know what
the hypothesis is we have a letter
written by a doctor that is written in
insane language at the request of Donald
Trump that's really who we should be
concerned about and and I agree we
should have Hillary Clinton's medical
records and we should have Donald
Trump's medical records but the idea
objectively that it's Hillary Clinton's
records that would be most concerning to
us if this guy is actually Trump's
doctor that's incredibly disturbing and
whenever she does I don't think she'll
actually you know serve Donald or the
media here and actually produce any
medical records but when and if she does
they're actually gonna be you know well
written not have typos actually makes
sense
well it'll I'm sure no matter what she
releases at this point it'll be like the
Obama birth certificate
where oh no I can tell in Photoshop that
the the layers are very very indicative
of the fact that this entire thing was
completely doctored and it's part of a
46 then for
six year conspiracy to get President
Obama elected at this point because of
the stuff that we're seeing on Infowars
Alex Jones etc no matter what Hillary
Clinton medical records are released you
are going to have people say that they
are absolutely not credible and and have
been doctored